we begin this morning with major
destruction from severe weather in the
upper midwest at least two tornadoes hit
minnesota including a town of florida
where officials say about half of the
community is gone pauline lee from our
minneapolis station wcco is on the scene
pauline good morning
good morning we're getting a first look
at the damage left behind after a
suspected tornado tore through the small
town of farada minnesota right here this
is the root of a tree much taller than i
am but if you take a walk right around
the corner you see just how massive this
tree is and the damage it left to this
home
this is the destruction left behind
after winds topped 90 miles an hour
ripping apart homes and buildings
dark ominous clouds kicked off the
unofficial start of summer in douglas
county minnesota bringing with them
torrential rain and destructive winds
the town of floreda took a direct hit
from a suspected once in a decade
tornado with winds reported to have
reached 80 miles an hour that's tough it
really is i've lived here for over 33
years and
it rips your heart apart for rada fire
chief stefan van lueck estimates up to
100 buildings and homes were demolished
in the city of around 160 residents
debris blocked every road into the town
delaying first responders who eventually
went door to door checking on residents
and amazingly they reported no major
injuries or deaths
i've never seen nothing like this not
even in your wildest dreams southeast of
ferreida and saint cloud there were
about three booms and then you could see
the sparks on the
on the
power lines dangerous wind gusts
uprooted trees and snapped power lines
leaving some without electricity the
storms stretched into sioux falls south
dakota where winds barreled through
tearing the roofs off homes and sending
trees into cars god nobody is hurt glad
it's only this damage
vehicles are replaceable lives are not
and back here in this small town of
ferreita hit especially hard it has a
population here of just a couple hundred
meaning nearly every resident knows
someone who's been affected by this
storm tony
pauline lee with wcco pauline thank you
very much